know there's a lot of haters out there
and they always say the same thing to me
i'm in the grocery store i'll take
walking the dogs
people stop me on the street and they
say i knew you would never show your
face again
yeah they look at me and they say nice
wig
nice wig ow ela your hair looks awesome
dude why don't you
so ela okay let me give you some
background it's not a wig
ela the skaters are gonna hate
your hair looks awesome you look great
thank you you have like these beautiful
eyes that work really good with the gray
color it looks awesome
somehow like your the hair like
lightened your eyes really
yeah like more gray they look more gray
i feel like that's something my mom
would say
really thank you you're welcome we
noticed details about you
and so well here's the thing though you
start this has anyone ever heard of this
before
ela started doing her hair at 10 a.m
and guess when she finished dan guess
when she finished i already told him
oh i told you already she finished doing
her hair
at like past 10 p.m
yeah it was over 12 hours stop
it was and i was starting to get
irritated because like
she just sit like [ __ ] i mean what the
[ __ ]
my hair is so dark and it's thick and
it's a full head of hair
and also the guy wanted to do it
responsibly
so he wanted to do it in sections so
that when he finishes one
section he's not still working up here
and then that goes too long
he did a good job abe why don't you tell
him what you just said before the show
that happened to lina
what uh lena was going from dark to
light once and like it took like
they kind of rushed it i guess because
it only took like six hours but her hair
started like fall out and chunks
like she was like crying in the middle
and it's like so bad
i guess that's who knew that it took you
had to spend so much time
so they made the blunder that he was
trying to avoid it sounds like yeah
because they probably bleached her
all over her hair and i couldn't get it
off so much patience i was thinking to
myself this is the most patient
guy yeah he was whoever existed so
lena's hair
started falling out got overcooked yeah
wow like it chunks and like days after
she was still like
oh yeah oh my god i felt so good
was it it was a while ago because she
has really
long hair no i'm sorry what was it was
that ago
oh yeah it was a while ago it was like
two or three years ago
was it falling out in the chair as they
were cutting it
yeah so what happens at a situation do
they still want her to pay
yeah they still want to pay and it
didn't even turn out like blonde it
wasn't like
blonde blonde it was yeah so like a
darker blonde
i love when someone like [ __ ] up their
service so bad and then you still have
to pay
yeah well that will be six hundred
dollars
i mean it's six hours bro you hate
yourself right now you still need to pay
for it
all right well i did it i finally did it
i think the podcast was
what pushed me to it because we kept
talking about it
how like i always wanted to do something
and my parents wouldn't let me
and so i was like time to
take charge of my own life um
you should show the whole look that
you're working with for sure
i put a hole just put your boots up yeah
just throw them
and it's like no one's gonna see it just
throw the boots up okay well
i gotta this is the shirt that i made at
first
handmade and then we re produced it
oh this is the reproduction this is the
reproduction that we'll sell
let's see the boots
yes mistress yes mistress
[Laughter]
yes mommy thank you that's hot
thank you to all our members you guys
make it all possible
members we love our members
i would fondle what would i i would do
terrible things to our members
don't say that i would do anything for
them
and you would do real thank you thank
you i mean you're you're
just be really nice you'd be like oh
you're such a nice person
no i wouldn't i would do terrible things
flatter them for them not
to them they would be like ethan i want
you to [ __ ]
lick my butthole before i wipe don't be
like yes mistress
no yes mistress i'm just saying i'll do
terrible feel free to unstop
what i'm trying to make this happen dude
why are you undermining my work
anyway thank you you know we didn't um
we didn't have a pre-release today an
early release for the
for the members which this way came in
yeah we've just been kind of backed up
with all the
scare from last week and we're trying to
figure out new formats for the show
let's be honest the uh make ethan laugh
was was
it was fine but it was it didn't hit
hard
no so i have an idea for another show
that i want to try next week that we
will pre-release for our mem
our beautiful members i did feel like um
for once i actually felt like i was able
to read constructive criticism in the
in the comments and not like feel like
oh these are just haters you weren't
involved at all in the
in that one maybe did you feel like well
no i i thought no there was a lot of
constructive criticism
that i agreed with you know there's a
difference between people are like
obviously fans of the show and then like
when you go on a random reddit thread
where
there's like a clip of you you think you
should just quit already yeah
wow like he's still yeah you know people
say the meanest [ __ ] [ __ ] about you
and it's like damn
stop you know but hey
forget about it we here we here baby
[Applause]
i was wondering do i just look like andy
warhol now
i'm you don't look like andy world like
a bowl
cut you don't your hair looks bomb dude
you're like uh milk you're like a milf
uh
billy eilish oh that's cool milf billy
island i like that
he's so beautiful oh vin diesel likes
the hair uh-oh what do you think about
ela's uh hair bin
but i go for blondes or brunettes i go
for anyone who'll go for me
oh is that new yeah well it sounds like
he says he'll go for anyone they'll go
for a man
but that's not well then well based on
the interview we saw that's not exactly
true because
she didn't really seem interested but
you were very
aggressive so not always
not always okay vin diesel
he's uh added some to his rep did we get
like a vin diesel expansion pack
yeah how much was this dlc
today's episode is sponsored by quip and
honey
we love them okay here's the exciting
announcement
it's been a long time but we finally
added new items to the h3h3shop.com
including i'm happy to announce
this smells like my butthole
all prophets go to colon cancer
research and help we found was it
we already found a charity it doesn't
say on here but it's like the [ __ ]
ass
cancer society no oh oh
yeah probably knows i'm sorry and why do
you
well yeah no
i know it was something like prostate
cancer society something straightforward
so we're here to support our and and you
know yesterday was men's day so we're
here to support our men
yeah so that's exciting
there's a limited quantity so hurry now
and get yours while supplies last
this is kind of epic that we made this i
have to say
pretty impressive i'm excited for people
to get it
and maybe film the reaction if you buy
one of these film the reaction
to one that's a fantastic idea and send
us the videos because that would be so
fun because i guarantee you
this truly is uh a horrific scented
candle and
and there's really nothing like it on
the market i would dare to even say
so buy this oh it makes a really good
christmas present because people are
just going to be like it always takes
like a season
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] that is just so [ __ ]
terrible you can really learn how long
how long it travels how long it takes
what i recommend to do is just be like
hey merry christmas everyone
push the candle out light it and see how
long it takes for people to notice
you know and then people will be like oh
and when you
know it's even worse they'll be like
damn like burning what does that smell
and you'll be like oh
it smells like my butthole have you
heard of that
and then they eat their blueberries i
just want people's genuine reaction to
to this candle existing booty perfume
perfume booty perfume
it's gross you touch the wax and then
smell your finger
do it come on you look for me come on
touch the wax smell your finger
i did it oh it's [ __ ] hard
dude
[Music]
and uh i just want to give a [ __ ] and to
uh to liam
our fan liam who made this all happen
and his crew at aroma aroma prime
oh yeah the geniuses in the lab at aroma
prime who came up with that wonderful
smell
uh thank you again thank you thank you
you are the man for making that happen
i am so impressed by by the work
that they did so aroma prime geniuses
[ __ ] dude my fingers smell like i just
itched my [ __ ]
it's amazing i mean i really delivered
um besides this though
let's see we got all kinds of fun new
merch of course
who could i don't okay don't don't even
ask me to explain it don't explain too
much
pedophile santa because last year we did
vaping santa and that was like our big
thing
i changed the name to inmate santa to
avoid the the whole pedophile hang on
okay
yeah that makes sense but it's pedophile
santa
here how do i get a close-up of the
graphic here
it's santa on a uh
what do you call that a lineup yeah
would you trust this man to deliver
packages to your children think again
daddy so it started with like a hegel
santa
whatever and then and then we were like
well let's put them up
i was like you know let's put him up in
the lineup and then
call him a pedo i think it's time we
confront that
the nasty truth that santa most likely
is a pedo because
you know it's like just look at the
circumstantial evidence you know
guy comes in the middle of the night
and everybody's sleeping he's bringing
breath he's leaving presents for the
kids
he's got kids on his naughty list
whatever that means right
or nice whatever nice means you know
let's be honest
the dude is a [ __ ] i would not trust
santa around my kids god
[ __ ] no and then this is kind of like
our ugly
sweater pedo santa where that's your
christmas uh party
i think it's gonna be a hit i think
people are going to take notice
we put the vape sleeves does that fit
well
on there well no it doesn't
no it doesn't really but i wanted to put
something on the sleeve
and um maybe it should have been jail
bars or something
they're saying content cord santa
no it's like real court santa this one
is the gerd gang
you know it's another fan made
illustration oh yeah someone at discord
made this what was her name
her name's uh kath cass she's great look
at this she's
uh two of these designs are from her she
uh she's a talent
and i really like this shirt gerd gang
so if you want to represent your game
there you go yeah i'm pretty happy with
this stuff this year you know
kurt gang oh the h3 podcast uh
class of 2020. we got all of our
yearbook photos because we had this
great segment
and uh ian stole the show honestly i'll
buy a shirt with just ian yeah
i honestly just want a picture of ian's
like that like
that's true like can we is it too late
to do that dan can we just get a shirt
of ian's face
and it's a i don't want that we need the
inspiration for that
oh we do ian can we do that yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
and then you might want to renegotiate
for that one
yeah actually good point dan thank you
good point then
that should be your manager all the all
the proceeds is being divided up among
the gang like we did last year
so these are going to support everybody
it is not just making mr monopoly
trillionaire me
richer right
yeah in fact last year if i can even go
as far to uh
talk myself up like we gave all of the
money to them
so that's a surprise so
this year no they don't get everything
well it was a surprise last year so yeah
but they probably will yeah
they'll probably get everything to split
amongst themselves it's like a behavior
bonus last year was it was great and uh
so please support us
h but yeah can we get a picture of ian
and i like what the captions say
um be careful who you make fun of in
high school
and then on the back i want to put a
picture of ian now
you know what i mean ian it's like uh
don't make fun of this
you you know what i'm saying without the
picture of him now i think just that
is so powerful do you like the caption
be careful you make fun of in high
school
i do if it's really small yeah like like
when you make fun of someone that it
shows me now and it shows how
your word spiral someone's
whole like the twist the whole sentence
you can ruin their life
wow so so wow
ian make it happen your girlfriend's the
graphic designer
like is that photo in full color ian
yeah i think it should be a full collar
and like super 80s like
soft vibes
yeah okay so yeah i'll go design my own
humiliation yeah
we'll get that out there we love it
i think that one will be popular i would
wear that proudly and then there's
another one by the same girl kath
while you were partying i studied the
blade it's awesome
i love that and there's one more
um this one which is the
the ensemble the whole ensemble together
and one shirt
we got we got a b dan a.i.e
and zach the pups it's all happening
here today on the
stream podcast after dark live
there you have it cool so support the
niche
gabish i'm getting a lot of donations
about ila's hair
oh i'll go ahead and read some um so
carolyn says ela you queen i'm a
hairstylist and have dreamed of this
moment it looks fantastic you did a
great job
this looks gives me vibes babe
thank you said daniel said ela is a hot
punk mom we all dreamed about
uh shanti i believe said elo where did
you get your jacket
supreme baby there you go and clay said
ela's new hair now that's what i call
hip-hop
[Laughter]
and then james for five dollars says
have you guys discussed vin diesel's
newfound love for tick tock
what wait what no yeah yeah i guess
vin diesel's into tick tock now i don't
all right i'm on it i don't know if i'm
ready for 20 20 vin diesel though
because i feel like he's probably a
normal guy now
no he's not no no he's already dude he's
already put out two crazy ass singles oh
yeah
that's true yeah that's true
so i think he's married with kids no
he's no longer like talk to me baby
does he have kids well well i mean dad's
dads definitely are pretty creepy i
don't know i wouldn't put anything past
okay okay i wouldn't put anything past
that man
talk to me baba okay so you guys
remember the ace family content core
and the sound bite that we love to use
where the guy going stop
well if so we discovered somebody
pointed out to us that
if you watch back the original video you
can hear the guy yelling stop
in the background so it's kind of hard
to hear you have to listen closely here
listen ready
the pool
oh my god so like but my what i'm
thinking is like
if we could hear it they could
definitely hear it
oh my they definitely heard the guy
saying stop and they ignored the poor
guy
why he's like look at the scene here
watch the scene because he's going
it's so serene and beautiful and the
pool and the jet ski
and my life is perfect and the guy's
like stop you're ruining my yard
yeah right yeah yeah he's displacing a
[ __ ] load of water
you freaking give me anxiety every day
hey family you only live once like i
always say so why not live it up look at
this
for where i am throw me the camera come
here so here it comes
just man just look at this the jet ski
the pool you hear it
stop hit me with that zach hit me with
the stop sound bite
that is priceless stop so now here
match it up stop here look at this for
where i am throw me the camera come in
the camera
just man just look at this the jet ski
the pool
i have the quiet one isolated too what
i have the quiet one isolated as well
yeah hit it
[Music]
dude you know you heard him
oh you can see how much water is on his
like grass down here
wow what bro you are out of [ __ ]
control
stop stop
because you know there was a big i was
wondering could he hear him
yeah oh he definitely heard it the jet
ski
the pool i love them
made from the perspective of everyone
that suffered
second hand the making of a video
that's a really good sketch idea the
youtube are
not even youtubers now it's like tick
talkers or even yeah the big ones like
influencer the influencer uh yeah
casualties oh
so good so shout out to whoever sent us
that
stop play that and then play the quiet
one zach
stop
[Music]
playing closer so it's like an echo
play the lava and then the quiet one
stop
[Music]
it's so good it's the best thing ever
all right oh that's from lucas shout out
to lucas my man
my [ __ ] legend okay you got you guys
tell me what you think because like
after dark i've got all this content i
want to talk to you guys
about but then we have a tons of video
clips
so what i'm thinking for a fourth
episode that we could pre-record and
release early for the
members is a clips show ethan point 0
help us think of a name if you guys like
the idea but it's just me reacting to
internet clips viral clips
so a couple of ideas was fat idiot
watches online
reacts to online videos maybe we could
think of an acronym or something
or like i like it i always thought
ridiculousness was such a dumb
title so something like uh it would be
funny if we could title that
retardedness but we can't
yeah that would be funny
yeah but you can't do it but like just
just just to make fun of that dumb
[ __ ] show yeah idiot-ness idiotness it's
just
it doesn't have the same yeah um
you got retardedness you got ethan poino
or you got like ethan
because touchpanel i mean i i guess you
guys got kind of defensive of taj last
time
fat [ __ ] loser watches dumb stupid
[ __ ]
here people are throwing in stop 4.0 4.0
guard.now i mean i'd like
equals h three h3 one
h3 we're coming up with an equation here
yeah e equals h three squared over there
just when you said it
e equals h three the thing is i want a
title that like
fart indicates idiot reacts to fart
oh fat fart smart fat
oh yeah the idiot there's that's not a
good acronym
oh it doesn't happen yeah it's a bad
acronym
but i want a title that like describes
what you could do flirt
which is fat lame idiot
reacts what's that cram oh blurt
flirty stupid i made that up i wanna
i mean i want a title that like first of
all says what the
series is and two doesn't turn everybody
off immediately from clicking on it
ethan flirts ethan farts i mean guys
come on we want wordlessness
greatness curtis-ness
funny oh my goodness
jew reacts reacts that's kind of good in
a weird way
because it's just so shocking and odd
not good jew reacts
you're only going to to like weirdos
like i don't even know what
but people could never forget that you
react
i don't know i kind of like it because
it's so ridiculous oh you don't
no you don't i thought it was kind of
good because it's just so odd
jew reacts rolls off the tongue
fart is fat [ __ ] reacts to
fart so what would you call it though
ethan farts i mean it doesn't sound like
anything i would want to watch
the fart compilation yeah i don't know
but that's the name we want
you could actually get a thing that's
clickbait
yeah every episode because it's not art
it's not a fart calculation
2.0 i mean people are vetoing the jew
thing guys
house of gerd what why why don't we just
call it ethan react
i mean ethan reacts oh my god acidic
acidic acidic acidic
acidic but see that title no one it
doesn't mean anything
no it does it's just funny i am a
hasidic
well i'm not a sea dick oh wow jews is
just ethan watching show or you could
you could do just watching the jews the
jews
jews react jews react
just ethan watching stuff what about
ethan reacts let's be honest maybe you
should pitch it to
the fine bros if they want to do a spin
off juice react
that would they do they would not
hesitate to do that
they were yeah they are there you've got
to be like okay let's do jews elderly
jews react to nazi imagery
they would do [ __ ] like that jews react
to nazi imagery
jewishness african americans uh react to
uh
slave era movies
ethan reacts let's be honest that says
it all right
react hard so i saw something they react
are that's pretty funny
[Music]
more more bait obesity that's the title
what is that what does that mean all
right well keep sending them
keep an eye on those guys because i do
want to good
fat ashkenazi i'll fart
you guys keep keep the suggestions
coming keep an eye out for some good
ones guys
jewish halal show
jews don't do hello hello parts for me
[Laughter]
do kosher kosher reactions
that's not bad deliciousness judas
liciousness
the problem with the like ironic title
like that like ridiculousness is that
it gets lost in the sauce and people
just think
you actually think that's a good title
yeah
you know ethan knightley
yeah clickbait academy
idiot reacts live which is irl
all right i'm gonna you should i watch
this or should we keep reading
i think we had enough probably all right
samurai hairstyle stop
sitting in hats she's sitting in hats
live
so ila is this the guy who cut your hair
last night
[Music]
fire and blade you know what i'm saying
[Music]
is
this dude swinging swords around my
[ __ ] head yeah you know i mean he's
definitely
he's definitely taking someone's ear off
or dug into their shoulder like you're
telling me accidents don't happen with
this dude
you know what i mean this guy is not
some like disciplined
samurai and you know
a little cut here
sometimes
bro what are you guys
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah practical it's a
bunch of little claws and burning and
samurai
salmon sword is the epitome of practical
hair cutting
this guy is really like the art of
ruining your hair
he's burning it that's not good i don't
think so whenever
i burn anything it looks awful
afterwards
thing i don't think these women know
he's terrible i think i think they know
he's a terrible hairdresser i think they
just like
you know the whole vibe it's like that
housewife dream boy
so tell me if you think her hair looks
has like oh scissors what a [ __ ]
loser
oh he uses ten scissors at once oh my
god
and someone is
i don't think that makes a difference
they should do like this with a blow
dryer
it's probably all like uh burned
well it always looks good in the in the
uh salon
i think the true test is when she gets
home and like yeah layers are all crazy
i don't like it
[Music]
to try to light one of his farts to cut
your sideburns
[Music]
stay still
you know you know how like back
i love that [ __ ] sound bite you know
back in the day
um different dojos like the
the sensai would go to different dojos
and challenge the other
sensei to take over their their students
i imagine those other hairdressers who
show up with samurai swords
to take over their their hair salon
oh my god
all right you want to talk about gavin
newsom
stupid idiot
um yeah we have kenneth copeland let's
do that
which is the best name right now because
there's like all these memes about
coping with
uh donald trump losing the fact that his
name is copeland is
so funny so here's then here's kenneth
we've talked about kenneth because he's
a he's a tele
televangelist who
is such an evil [ __ ] i mean his whole
face is just demonic you know
people people say his face he looks like
the villain from the mask
do you have those memes i sell them on
the subreddit and they're really
accurate
why don't you guys grab that real quick
yeah
um man this guy is something so
here's how he reacts to president trump
losing the election
the media said what
the media said joe biden's president
don't you dummies know god decides who's
president
why don't all things are possible with
god
what i don't get is like god if god god
did decide who's president
joe biden won and you just you're you're
refusing to acknowledge god's will
you know what i mean it's like we only
agree with god we only call it god's
will when he does what we want him to do
god god spoke dude he didn't want your
guy
the media said what
the media said what joe biden's present
[Applause]
you know people talk about uh i think
it's two seconds from like taking a gun
out and just shooting
you know um people say about like all
these conspiracies about
you know uh democrats drinking baby
blood and [ __ ] i mean this [ __ ]
drinks baby butt
yeah trust me on that
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
you know god decided man he
he was there if he's all powerful trust
me you know he this
this played out how he wanted don't
laugh in god's face
i love it they just they refuse to
accept god's will all of a sudden
i guess there is like uh laughter
therapy right i guess that's kind of
like what they're doing
subconsciously reminds me of like
serenity now insanity later
look at this he is oh there was like a
whole like three
slide yeah that is him
three slots there's three different
expressions
so oh my document get that off there
so let's see we have some other copeland
stuff oh
you know we talked about him he's the
guy who goes all things are possible
with god
yeah except trump winning apparently
you know what i mean that was the one
thing he couldn't do
[ __ ]
this guy's such a piece of [ __ ] you guys
fear of this
this coronavirus is is faith in its
ability to hurt you or kill you
uh the the the fear
what are we going to do what are we
going to do
yeah you got to sound like that one zach
what are we going to do what are we
going to do
hey your job's not your source
if it is you're in trouble you bet you
[ __ ] ask the job as the source
jesus is your source jesus ain't putting
food in my stomach
no it's his source yes your source
you've done well
yeah off of jesus jesus is your source
but not mine
you know what i mean jesus is your
source
jesus jesus is your source
this is the guy who by the way he went
viral we talked about him years ago when
he was like
some journalist ambushed him on his
private jet he owns like a 200 million
dollar
private jet that clips in the dock too
right now yeah okay yeah
so this guy is a total [ __ ] i mean evil
evil dude
who doesn't pay taxes by the way you
know you know i've heard i
he's a he's a religion it's it's jesus
christ and all that
and and the church doesn't pay taxes
but this guy is like all politics you
know it's like there needs to be some
i mean this guy should be paying [ __ ]
taxes
he's cruising around and private jets
and mansions
he's talking about politics let's tax
this [ __ ] what's your loophole
what are we going to do i mean
scientology
they don't pay taxes yeah that was a
huge scandal though scientology was like
uh
they basically strong armed the
government they were going to attack
scientology and then they like
started suing everybody in government
and ruining everybody's lives and [ __ ]
and they were like okay you can
yeah i i want to be kurt gang's a
religion the [ __ ] am i paying attention
jesus is your source jesus is my source
pay taxes on that [ __ ]
hey you guys all owe me 10 of your
income that's what the church says you
guys all owe me 10 of your income come
on
if it is you're in trouble
jesus is your source whatever you do
right now don't you stop tithing
so tithing don't you stop maybe i'm the
only because i'm like a jew and
kind of an atheist agnostic
tithing is when you but all the uh it's
a christian thing or a catholic thing i
don't know it's
jesus thing you pay 10 of all of your
income to the church
so that's what tithing is so he says
times might be tough because of the
kovid but don't you stop tithing
that sounds insane people really do that
bro yeah ten percent overdoing that was
skippy was saying he was gonna do
that's like uh an agent fee
that's what they do man they're yeah
exactly
they're all so hollywood without knowing
there they invented that [ __ ] asian
fee man
stop sewing offerings well they won't
let us go to church
well email it in there text give or
something but you get your tithe in that
church
if you have to go take it does this guy
pay tithe
honest billion dollars a year i'd like
to know who he tithes to
[ __ ] her i bet you he doesn't but the
guest
he's like i own the church who's tithing
drop it off in the un stick it under the
door or something
you get that tithe in that church you
get that offering in that church and
then you go home
and you do what we're supposed to do
that's just weird like even if it's
um even if it comes from a good place
the whole concept of that ten percent
yeah no exemption for that it's just
weird to see him
demand it like that yeah i mean you and
then
well and then and then see it next to
this one here people are not even
working right now
see see him demanding it next to this
we'd just like to ask you about why you
don't want to
fly commercial why have you said that
you won't fly commercial you said that
it's like hit me with that
you have any 10 sound bites now's a good
time into a tube with a bunch of demons
why do you think oh yeah he said flying
coaches is like being on a tube with a
bunch of demons dude
guys listen to me just sing
not the people the main reason
is because of the need if
if i flew commercial i'd have to stop 65
percent of what i'm doing
that's really to me isn't it true that
you want to fly commercial so that you
can fly in luxury
how much money did you pay for tyler
perry's golf stream jet for example
well for example that's really none of
your business but
isn't it the business of your donors
this woman's amazing
i paid he's so not down with this
he's ready to kill him guard here okay
certainly well
if you like to come out here i'd like to
give you a chance to to
catch your breath and just have a
conversation we don't want it
i'd love to see our politicians being
grilled like this
sad edition you got to get this now hey
you listening to me
my wife thinks inside edition is oh yeah
now got him thank you lord help me just
let me pray well let me let me just ask
you a really simple question
a lot of people i think is one becoming
for a preacher
he's got demonized bro straight up demon
eyes live a life of luxury and to fly
around in private jets
what's your response to that very simple
it takes a lot of money to do what we do
we have brought over a hundred let's see
this the latest figures just came out
he's sweating man
uh 122 million people to the lord jesus
christ
let me give you another example last may
i was scheduled for
lagos nigeria as a long ways
i had a week off and i was scheduled
for peru and i prayed about it and i
thought
i'm not missing that dedication in
jerusalem
without the airplane that we have that i
bought from tyler
perry and i didn't pay anywhere tyler's
one of the greatest guys
he made it's he made that airplane so
cheap for me i couldn't help but buy it
well my question then can you look it up
can you look up how much you paid for
the plane what is that supposed to use
he made it so damn cheap it was only a
hundred million dollars
this person said in germany you pay
seven percent
church tax by default collected out of
your monthly paycheck oh yeah i've heard
about to get rid of it you have to
excommunicate from your religion
yeah i that's yeah that i learned well i
went to germany for exchange trip in
high school and that [ __ ] blew my
[ __ ] mind
and and they take it straight out of
your [ __ ] check bro
they never knew they garnish your wages
oh yeah foreign exchange student
yeah yeah yeah i don't think you've ever
mentioned that
i really was a long time ago i was in
high school yeah i went to germany for a
while experience though
it's just a month yes okay it was like a
whole semester or something
this article from the washington post
said 54 million
he made it so damn cheap for me youtube
i just had to buy it
54 dude tyler perry is rich as a
[ __ ]
bro also someone else here said
uh 100 christian thing
catholic churches just do donations with
those weird baskets
yes an important note i'm down with the
catholic [ __ ] don't like the concept
so correct me if i'm wrong the catholics
are the people who are just do whatever
they want kind of vibe
no or is that the or catholic is the
pope [ __ ]
yeah so what's the difference in
christian
the [ __ ] is christian catholic because
the pope is catholic is that the
christian thing
there was this thing called the schism
uh the schism
or rather the schism was when the
orthodox church broke off it's the
reformation
uh you know like martin luther you've
probably heard of before
catholicism used to be the dominant like
the one big christian religion but it's
it's since broken off into tons of
subgroups but isn't it christianism
isn't christianity like the whole yes
christianity is really
because she said it's a christian thing
um the comments well the tithing is
in the new testament i believe uh yeah
oh it's in the new testament guys come
on
the guy who's the guy who's like and
also you have to give me 10
of your money no i can't find it again
okay well copeland
sorry okay all right but i want to get
to the demons because people are very
concerned about that comment give me a
chance your inside edition
i love your eyes and uh calm down
here's what happened
we flew in 21 days
70 hours 40 000 miles there's a part
where he gets really upset i know we
watched this video but man it's so good
just running off all this like he
there's a part where he gets really mad
here i think it's like right here he
like snaps
people i'm talking about the bible the
blessing of abraham
the blessing of abraham look at his neck
his neck [ __ ] jiggle when he shakes his
head
and he had a covenant with god not
it's not the jewish blessing it's the
abrahamic blessing
we don't like that excited talking about
it because i love it
and i started out
deep in debt with if you believe in
anything which is another story
that anyway guy i would believe is evil
yeah i mean everything he everything he
talks about is just
so i think that the gimmick with him is
like he and and other preachers like him
these evangelicals they preach uh i i
forget the
the total name of it but it's like uh
rich like they say like if you believe
in god god blesses you with
riches literal monetary wealth that's
his
way of showing that he loves that uh
prosperity gospel yeah process so
so like they found a way to convince
people
that if they gave their money to him
that they would also get rich so it's
almost like a lottery thing
it's almost like a pyramids god pyramids
game you know
someone just gave me their time
how much was it you said five dollars
bro come on that ain't off
were you telling me you made only fifty
dollars this month
well step up your donations man get
those tithes in the door
i don't care what you're going through i
don't care how our time it is
if you if you think money is your source
i'm your source
get that ten percent
[Laughter]
[Music]
and from my spiritual mentor oral
roberts
and um i learned it from him
working with him and then we became he
was close friends until he died
and and he took the same heat for
believing god would prosper you that
i've
taken over the years and
abraham was very very wealthy said
something
he said i was raised in a catholic cult
please be careful with what you say
about
catholicism it's incredibly damaging and
i've been in therapy for a long time to
recover
what does that mean that there's that i
need to do a trigger warning or
something
well because i think you you said
something like isn't the
catholic the ones that do whatever they
want it sounds like it's the complete
opposite
oh but there's okay but there's a sect
of
christianity that's like super chill
about everything right
there's plenty of them i mean they don't
believe in going yeah i guess it's uh
far from the there's a there's a huge
you know how there's
orthodox jews and reformed jews like you
can think about it like that but with
many many many more subdivisions than
judaism has oh
so it really depends but catholicism is
not the chill one
i'm pretty sure whatever you're thinking
of it's not okay yeah
but i'm kind of confused about please be
careful with what you say about
catholicism
huh okay
well granted i don't know anything about
catholicism so i'm glad you are
out and going to therapy to
undo whatever damage they did they gave
50 bucks so thank you for the tithe
yeah that's awesome although if you ask
me
i think i still think that you probably
made more than 500 bucks this month huh
i'll let you pass dude ten percent a lot
i think you're not joking yeah
i just want to point out we're getting
conflicting prices on the plane but he
does have supposedly three
so what three of them why the [ __ ] would
you need three planes yeah
well it's probably the church
organization has three planes not that
makes it better but
he probably personally doesn't own the
plane but obviously
come on dan chill
galatians chapter 3
if you belong
to christ all right shut up over
it that ended up taking a lot longer
than i thought we should um
do our little ad all right let's pay our
tithes let's do our tithes to our
sponsors
what do we got today we have
you know it you love it honey
joinhoney.com h3
you know about honey guys it's the free
online
shopping aid that clips coupons scours
the entire
internet for the best coupons and
automatically applies them at checkout
skirt gang honey is basically your
online shopping best friend
here's how it works you get honey on
your computer for free
and two easy clicks and then when you're
checking out on one of over 30
000 supported sites honey pops up and
all you have to do
is click apply coupons boom wait a few
seconds as honey
searches for coupons for that site if
honey finds the code
it'll apply the best one to your cart
we always save money with it that's
ridiculous
elo is a pretty heavy online shopper and
i mean
it's pretty safe to say you've saved
hundreds if not thousands of dollars
yeah i'm not i i would say that's not an
exaggeration
it's it's ridiculous it's free it's
super easy to stall
it's like a widely used widely trusted
reputable there's it's like a it's like
a win-win situation
you know uh it's founded 17 million
members
over two billion dollars in savings and
honey supports all kinds of of retailers
from tech and gaming sites to fashion
brands
and even food delivery it's so simple
if you have a computer honey should be
on it it's free and works with whatever
browser you use
you can get honey for free today at
joinhoney.com
h3 that's join honey.com slash
h3 so they know that we sent you so that
you can support your
super new super nation that's honey
thanks honey for supporting this episode
we love honey
and finally we have
oh an old classic eh quip quip
and all to quip i've missed you my
friend
you know about quip okay i'm obsessed
with oral hygiene
it's a pulsating tube you click it
listen to this mama mia come on baby
yeah the black one's pretty dope look
tooth brushing your teeth is kind of a
big deal
you know if you could go wrong you can
go wrong with brushing you can use too
much pressure
yeah you can get you can do it all wrong
first right right uh your the bristles
can be too hard
you can damage your gums i mean it's
there's so much
you cannot clean enough people say you
know what i've heard dentists say
there's the death creeps in through the
gums people who don't
don't tell me that people who well you
have clean gums i'm just saying
people who don't have good oral hygiene
die
sooner because all the bacteria in their
mouth and [ __ ] gets seeps into their
[ __ ] body i swear to god
why you have good teeth you take good
care of your mouth i try but it's
it's never enough i don't have urogenes
well just because your gums are receding
doesn't mean that
you're gonna die from having a [ __ ] up
mouth
you know your gums look healthy okay
yeah quit
this isn't their claim but i'm claiming
quip adds years to your life
here's how it works first of all it's
got the soft bristles that i love it
doesn't hurt the gums it feels natural
and beautiful
some of the best bristles in the game
you turn it on
it times two minutes and a pulsates
every 30 seconds to let you know
when to switch quadrants so because we
wait and you go up time to switch this
one we
wait time to switch this one two minutes
to make sure you get that perfect
dentist recommended brush
it's way cheaper than the competition
and it's frankly just as good
it's sleek it's easy to carry around
with you
it's got it all folks
they also deliver brush heads floss
toothpaste refills
every three months from just five
dollars shipping is free
you can save time and skip the store
this top pops off
you put on a new one bob's your uncle
you're ready to go
if you go to get quipped.com h3 right
now you'll get your first refill for
free
that's your first refill for free at get
quipped dot com slash
h3 that's spelled g e t
q u i p dot com slash
h3 that's quip better oral health made
simple oh yeah and they start at just 25
so
come on who are you kidding
thank you to our sponsors thank you very
much all right we're going to talk about
gavin newsom now
and i've been giving the um i've been
giving the republicans a lot of [ __ ] so
it's only fair that gavin duson gets it
from me today because that guy's a
[ __ ] idiot
what was he thinking you know i i didn't
have a strong opinion on gavin he seemed
to be doing well and
i don't know what's your opinion on get
do you have opinion on gavin newsom
are you asking me or then dan i knew it
uh i'm
i'm not a huge fan but um i don't know
why what didn't you like about him
before this whole
scandal uh i mean he's very much an
establishment
democrat in california which means you
know
he's kind of got a long history of some
controversial things
he was the mayor of san francisco for a
long time
and it's a lot of aggressive area now
it's a progressive area but i mean
the social situation in san francisco as
you're probably aware is
pretty awful the homelessness situation
and everything and
you know a lot of people lay a lot of
the blame for the current
state of san francisco at his leadership
the time that he was uh in charge there
so
but i don't know it's all kind of
hearsay
i don't really have a huge strong
opinion on him
but this [ __ ] is [ __ ] well he won the
governor's ship
so some people liked him but i mean he
was the lieutenant governor to jerry
brown for
many years so he was sort of coordinated
works in california so well anyway
gavin newsom has he you know has been
very
very for uh forceful with uh kovid he
called the statewide lockdown
he's been issuing a lot of mandates and
this and that's about covet
and even yesterday he issued a curfew
you know we have a month-long curfew in
california now
i didn't watch the news as of last night
as of last night in california
uh what what's the curfew 10 p.m
10 p.m to like 5 a.m only essential
travel how is how are people not already
doing that
but okay i mean there are restaurants
and
i'm not going anywhere i don't i don't
understand that like what is that aiming
to curtail like just bars and
restaurants because like
like heading out for pleasure which you
shouldn't really do right now
because i'm thinking like i don't do
anything in that time because you're
being safe
yeah yeah so it's like
you if you're meeting at 10 a at 10 p.m
you're meeting to like
hang out with friends drink drink and
then you start to get more
loosey-goosey it's alcohol business
thing
yeah so anyway there's that new
restriction but literally like a day
before
he was filmed uh
at this huge dinner party not social
distancing and nobody wearing masks
which is like
basically what every health official has
been saying don't do
especially with including him yeah well
including him
i just especially him i couldn't believe
it
and you know with thanksgiving coming up
late tonight by a woman this is the
exact type of
thing that um everyone's saying don't do
yeah thanksgiving is going to be such a
disaster i'm sorry to say but
yesterday we had 190 000 new cases 2 000
deaths
70 000 current hospitalizations and
there's so many people
that just you know they want to get
together for thanksgiving yeah i'm still
hearing from people that like their
families
still doing thanksgiving like different
people that i know
look and look i it's wild thanksgiving
is like the most uh
cherished american holiday where
everybody comes together
and it's coming off like the shittiest
year ever where everyone's isolated
i know so i understand people's desire
to do this they should cherish
each other more than a holiday that
you'll be able to do next year
i understand people want to do it but
the thing is that
now is the most dangerous time to do it
and i'm afraid that um come december
when we start seeing spikes like it's
already it's already out of control but
by the second week of december [ __ ] is
going to be so
crazy i'm hearing more and more people
now who know
other people that just got it like it's
getting like everyone knows someone that
has
it right now i can tell you like five
different people that just told me they
know someone that
has got it yeah so it's becoming like
really
the good thing the good thing is that
the the vaccine is like
right it's like literally right around
the [ __ ] corner but
these last the thing is like let's say
we get it available
they're going to start by vaccinating
all old people and frontline workers
which is you know well deserved and then
it's probably not going to be till
mid next year where the general public
is going to start getting access to it
so the good news is that the death rate
will fall off significantly with
with old people being uh vaccinated but
there's still going to be a [ __ ] ton of
tragic unnecessary deaths
and boy the next few months i'm just
telling you right now
as someone who's been right about covet
from the beginning so you should listen
to me
you may not listen to me on other things
but on this one i'm right
the next three months are going to be
catastrophic
catastrophic oh here a lot of people in
the chat
have covered or this person's mom has it
she's a hairdresser and she got it from
a client yeah you know
um the
problem of course with thanksgivings
dinner is that you bringing 10
20 30 people into a into a closed space
and even if everyone's wearing masks
you've got to take it off to eat you got
to sit around a table
one person's infected they don't know it
i mean you know
people are walking out of there with
covet who didn't have it before
that's for sure
december and january is going to be are
you guys going to get the vaccine when
it comes out
most definitely yeah as soon as it's
available i'll take that [ __ ]
[ __ ] immediately um
immediately i have it and i'm 15. i had
coveted me and my husband have it
wow there's a lot of people that have
coveted yeah
i never died from it his his what my
neighbor
oh she just died from it yesterday this
person said oh [ __ ]
it's really scary you really don't want
to play with it like i know
it really sucks i'm craving just hanging
out with people
just doing like regular things it's so
annoying the thing is
dying to go back to normal but it's
really scary until then it's not worth
it
the problem is that our government our
first of all congress has
completely and utterly failed failed us
uh they have completely and utterly
[ __ ] failed us as a society as a
nation
it's so unforgivable that
all americans have gotten is twelve
hundred dollars so many messages still
this person i have covered in anything
and it sucks
i still have um covered um side effects
i just wrote yeah that's the thing that
i'm
scares me is all these side effects and
lasting effects people don't know
the extent of what this virus does and
how my seven-year-old has it
oh no yeah that's [ __ ] that's really
[ __ ]
um congress has totally failed us
they've had one stimulus built
months ago and people are our lives are
being destroyed
people so many people are unemployed so
many people are being forced to decide
if they need to
go work or if they want to be safe and
frankly they don't have an option
because they need money yeah our
congress has totally
[ __ ] failed us to the point it's just
it's just
how are people are going to stay home if
they have to go work
to feed their friends they can't they
can't that's the thing it's like
sure you have a two percent chance of
dying from kobe but you have a 100
chance of dying if you don't have
[ __ ] money to feed your family
uh so obviously don't blame them but our
society is just
um there's no safety net and there's no
guidance and there's no
there's no leadership so at this point
you all you can do is do your best to
protect yourself so if you are in the
good fortune of being able to
stay home work from home not go to
thanksgiving all this [ __ ] i mean
you really just got to worry about
yourself at this point because like
nobody in our government and our society
is really trying to help
and it's just a nightmare and uh i'm
very afraid of what's going to come
in january by january it's going to be
crazy
you i i i think it's going to surprise
even me
but anyway just be careful man so anyway
back to gavin newsom this [ __ ]
after all that prelude here he is you
know damn
somebody really got his ass good by the
way
somebody was waiting for this [ __ ]
picture you know what i mean yeah
what was he thinking this is insane what
he was thinking is probably
well to give him that as much of the
benefit out he's probably thinking
we all got tested no it's all safe
yeah you gotta know better than that use
the government great
i agree and as the governor you have to
especially acknowledge how dangerous a
picture like this is
will be we've been invited by friends
that we would really love to see
but we're not gonna go i'm just trying
to say what
i think he was thinking i mean i
wouldn't go to this either
you know the other people at this dinner
were also like california medical
association
like heads and stuff so it's not just
him it's like
all of the medical leadership
aren't you actually just worried about
covert on a personal level you know what
i mean yeah
it's like forget that you're a governor
and that now that there's photos of you
doing this
you undermine your authority and your
messaging and now
do you know how many more people are
gonna go have thanksgiving dinner with
their family that maybe would have
thought about it because of you
[ __ ] doing this you stupid [ __ ]
loser
like so many people are gonna see this
vote and be like well the governor
governor's doing it so i'm gonna go up
thanksgiving dinner with my family
you [ __ ] you [ __ ] stupid [ __ ]
and the problem when you get invited
like you guys may get invited to
something and people will say oh it's
gonna be outdoors we'll sit outside
oh he lied about it but what happens is
that
people just don't stick to it you see
people you get moves
it gets cold outside you want to go
inside
it's just not going to stick and at some
point you're gonna find yourself inside
he lied to the press at first he was
like we were outdoors we were all taking
precautions and then they're like well
actually it was indoors and you had to
close the door because you're being
[ __ ] loud
stop there's no protocol here this is
like just straight up
era yeah what a douche i mean
dude sorry but this lapse of judgment is
kind of unforgivable
it's like because simply because the act
itself is whatever you know
he said we all make mistakes in poor
judgment which is like okay cool yeah
you're right but you're the [ __ ]
governor telling people to stay indoors
and your stupid decision to do this is
going to cost people lives
so people can see this and say i'm going
to go up thanksgiving family with my
you really [ __ ] up dude
it's it's just it's humiliating bro
someone is saying what if they
all had the vaccine and like
you know what even if they all know it's
safe
then you can't set this example to other
people
it just it doesn't matter how you look
at it if they all had the vaccine i mean
i don't
well if that's true there's no evidence
of it but yeah yeah
like you were saying it's the optics
right
they'll have the vaccine i'd like to
know why they got it before
they don't have they don't have the
vaccine i mean we have we have no
evidence to assume that
uh what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
he blew it he blew he did he blew it you
know
and i gotta give it up to i mean
biden's been really good on covent man
he's
he's been really good maybe he's just
more scared of it as he should
he's more scared yeah yeah somebody's
saying you gotta check my tick tock on
rudy giuliani that went viral last night
oh flank it i've got plenty of rudy
content here don't talk about rudy today
hey b can you get us that tick tock did
you hear the um
since we're talking about the vaccine on
a brighter note um
the whole news about this moderna
vaccine how it like
is potentially super beneficial even
beyond covid
no it's like this this vaccine that they
made is a whole new
type of vaccine that um that they've
been trying
to make work for years that's going to
open up like a ton of
is this the 95 what yeah it's like
it's like it's a type of vaccine where
they don't actually inject the virus
like you know oh it's a nasal spray no
no i think it's still an injection but
it's just that
they don't use dead bits of the virus to
vaccinate
they use like rna mrna technology to
like trick your body into producing
antibodies they've been trying to do
this for years and i guess because of
the massive
rush to find a corona virus uh extra
funding and stuff
right they've actually had like a major
breakthrough in that so yeah there's
maybe a little bit of good news
i want that good 95 yes
that sounds pretty good i'll take both
can i take both
and it get hot i got lana i got hairy
legs
okay joe well we're talking about covid
right now joe
this president says my mom told me that
kovid doesn't live in idaho and she
wanted to have thanksgiving and said if
i wear a mask she would laugh at me
yeah there's a lot of i'm sorry
unfortunately
um unfortunately there's a lot of people
who think
one of the saddest things i heard was a
nurse saying that
there's people literally dying of kovid
dying on a respirator who are still
thinking it's a conspiracy
and that it's something else and they
don't understand what's killing them
that's sad you know this is this is the
cost of having
you know a president that doesn't live
in reality
and it's the reason why there's two
almost 200 000 cases yesterday and 2 000
deaths
so
you know i don't know why people are so
callous about this it's it's so
odd it's just so odd
if people were dying in any other way
i'm just like i find myself dreaming of
um
what's going on in australia right where
there is
i think i think oh there's a lot of
countries that are like oh yeah new
zealand maybe
australia's kind of [ __ ] up okay so
new zealand sorry i saw uh
dj tiesto i believe his name he played
for a crowd in taiwan
yeah taiwan has like an ultra music
festival there
yeah so they're a lot of the asian
countries have performed a lot
better than the west well yeah because
wearing masks is uh
part of the social norm there yeah
people wear masks even before kovit
but also just being like obedient
to something it's like it has to be part
of the culture
because i'm seeing in israel it's the
same problem as here people don't listen
and it's really bad in israel too right
now well
it's true i mean you know in america we
have this rugged
individualism and freedom and everything
which you know
is true but i do think people would be
more willing to chip in
if there wasn't like there's that aspect
which is going to always be part of
american society which is part of the
cool and sometimes bad aspect in this
case bad
so like you can't discount that but
i think a lot more people would be
chipping in if we had
clear messaging and good leadership
if wearing a mask was portrayed as
patriotic
instead of being some kind of soy boy
beta cuck [ __ ]
like donald trump i you know i mean god
bless joe rogan but like even he
on his podcast is saying wearing masks
is isn't manly
i think he walked that back or he walked
it back well he
you know once you say it once the damage
is done taken out of context and he was
joking or whatever
well it's not it's really not that it's
like you know
[ __ ] this alpha male [ __ ] is actually
getting people killed now so
especially when you're saying it when
you have a staff doctor testing
everybody that comes into
10 feet within you your perimeter you
know
i just uh
yeah it's really just the [ __ ] this
whole
messaging that it makes you a baby or a
sheep or something
it's just [ __ ] crazy
we want freedom for the world
some somehow they equate wearing a mask
to a tyrannical breach of freedom
which they're still they're free not to
wear a mask right like that's the irony
of it
you know we're just asking nicely so
that people don't [ __ ] die
you know if two thousand people died in
a terrorist attack last time two
thousand people died in a terrorist
attack
how many people died in 9 11 dan it was
like 3 000 right i believe it was around
3000 3000 people died in a terrorist
attack
and we spent like a trillions of dollars
killing
[ __ ] millions of people in the middle
east um i just want to say
this person i think there's a great
attitude she's saying i love
wearing a mask it makes me feel less
anxious out in public
right i agree yeah totally i totally
agree
you get to cover half of your face what
else do you need
just a dream yeah no you don't need to
wear makeup you don't need to worry
about
right having some [ __ ] in your mouth
some teeth i got a i got a joker mask
and like there's been instances where i
scared the [ __ ] out of people put it on
it's in my car but i it's a mess yeah
it's like the full like smile
and it's like right under the eyes you
gotta get it go get it we'll wait
okay i gotta see this
of course zach walks around with the
joker here look only five cases in
australia somewhere oh oh
australia is doing really good okay five
cases in australia holy [ __ ]
oh you guys made it through the winter
too because it's he said
yeah well they just came out of the
winter and
but i just because i follow a few people
just like fashion bloggers and
sometimes i'll see their stories and
there i see this girl like in a party
and i'm like oh my god she's so
responsible to post that
and then i realized she post the next
story she's saying chill everyone i'm in
australia we're like back to normal here
yeah
i'm sorry for everyone else i know and
everyone's giving her all this [ __ ]
everyone's giving her [ __ ]
i'm reading the uh areas that
had corona severely in australia they
have super strict lockdowns though
and i think that's the thing is they
just can't do that here people
will not stand for it rise up they will
not get your dogs they're trying to
they go all of a sudden they go from
they go
to full on [ __ ] militia rise
up get your guns boys
and people from people who aren't even
in the lockdown area come down
like that kid kyle rettenger whatever
the [ __ ] come on boys get your guns
they're locking down a neighborhood in
new york
it's civil war tyranny is here
move on boys come on now boys get your
guns
you don't have to smell stinky uh breath
from people
this is what people are saying in the
chat there's a lockdown in queens boys
get your guns
the tyranny is here
anyway all right uh gavin newsom [ __ ]
up big time we
hate we don't like him boys there's a
neighborhood going into lockdown in
the bronx we're gonna grab our guns down
here in south carolina and head on up
to stop the tyranny
it's like doesn't even involve them here
comes zach
whoa jesus man that is kind of creepy
yeah
can't you get a normal mask
oh my god [ __ ] sick what are you
talking about
do you get a lot of looks when you walk
around like that is it embarrassing
no i love the attention you feel badass
yeah you feel people are scared of you
no there's been instances where they're
like holy [ __ ] bro you scared the [ __ ]
out of me
crazy ass zach's always up to something
yeah i would probably freak if i said i
i might do a double take on you
i probably i probably walk an extra
large circle around you you know
12 feet instead of six
uh fan so there's more okay so here
vin diesel friends of the show
so we found out that vin diesel has a
facebook page where he's been
well been posting cringe memes for years
years you understand so let me take you
a walk through vin
vin diesel posted this one race one love
one world what what race is this
i don't know man the pixel man
look at this [ __ ] great inspiration we
will find a way or we will make one
oh my god he looks like a like he's four
feet tall in this
why is he so short
what do you think makes the photoshop
for him
i'm thinking what happens is people just
send them to him and he thinks they're
all cool and repost them
why is he so short look how short he is
isn't he short in real life but this
guy's like four feet
whoever this like right am i crazy oh no
he's six feet
um maybe because he angled it's an
ancient greek
warrior they were shorter back then i
don't know
okay looks like a obvious spartacus
thing uh vin diesel this was his profile
photo at one point i swear to god
look how beautiful she is i love that
you can kind of tell it's him though
kind of
talk to me baby let me see if i shrink
it a lot if you can tell
what the [ __ ] is that not really it
doesn't really help
i was wondering you know here's van like
kicking through some paper what
i don't know why this is really weird
he's such an icon
it looks like you're you're in a
bathroom in japan or you're changing in
japan you know
they're like made of paper some walls
you're in a paper
you're in the you're in the room
changing and then
and you look over and you see this
vin book activated password accepted
35 million family members online
is that meant to be his hand because
that perspective is not right
don't give me baby
i really do love our planet cool nice
quote
cool dude
me too man i really do love our planet
you should write a book
this is uh i really don't know but there
he is
oh what the [ __ ] apple's right
one side is like nature what's going on
hey vin diesel what's going on in this
photo
am i right or wrong i think you're wrong
i don't get it
he's like living on the edge really look
how beautiful she is
yeah you do look good he's like living
on the edge of society and nature he's
this bird i think that's the message
he's the verb bird on the edge of
everything
but the pineapples don't make any sense
those are those are out there
i love you thank you
you angels can turn hate to love change
poison into medicine
and replace doubt with dreams
[Music]
beautiful look at his face
you know he thinks he's a sex like him
but he's kind of a odd looking dude
i mean he's jacked so i accept the
action
action hero stuff but
i hope you always have a reason to smile
what is this a [ __ ] like
[Laughter]
poster from your uh
you know your your your preschool like
hospital nurse room
[Laughter]
thanks fam here he is on a tiger what
wow wow that's the weirdest
frank lloyd what about this 27 million
let's go
angels do exist
[Laughter]
it's all distorted talk to me baby seven
pagili oh he looks like he's drinking
all fours
just the right hype what's the joke ashy
song
so many people and still one reaches for
his inner peace
what in the [ __ ] so many people and
still one reaches
for what is that for
life what does it say
it doesn't really make sense
but he's he's not on his level
finn is not enlightened i mean i don't i
could tell you
i don't know i just feel like someone
who is enlightened doesn't post this
stuff
you know what i mean oops jesus
he calls it vin book oh he's a fairy
this time
okay i gotta read this let me zoom in
he says positive he says positivity is
free here
for the taking inspiration awaits only
to be recognized
and confidence is always encouraged
however please
enter our world with caution for there
are angels abound
and if you are unaccustomed to love and
compassion you
may be in for a shock he's making these
because he says
like like there's no way he just said
that he's talking about vin book
he made this did the evidence
the vin book yeah does he have a book we
will oh [ __ ]
bro he did a 911 [ __ ] oh god
with comic sans we will never forget
here he is on the phone man
i know that um ian has been reading the
matthew mcconaughey
book it sounds like it's actually good i
mean how was that
yeah it's it's it's a good read
yeah it's funny i thought it was just
going to be a book of quotes
yeah it's autobiographical right
yeah but he has a lot of stories that
i'm like did this really happen
right like he had a yeah like a two-page
description of his dad giving cpr to a
bird and bringing it back to life
that drowned in his toilet bowl and
that's it like really yeah yeah i saw
him interviewing everywhere when the
book came out and
he told some of the stories and i had
the same reaction like
you know what's funniest howard howard
stern did an interview with him and he's
like a lot of the stuff in here is like
super [ __ ] up and matthew's like no
it's all good and howard's like no
you're really
the fact that you don't understand how
[ __ ] up this is is concerning
like he's like uh he's like a paul
bunyan character
you know larger than life
well let's get some howdy's going it
does sound interesting though
either can you can i turn your attention
to this how could drops of water know
themselves to be a river yet the river
flows on
he looks so stupid in the drought he's
in a drop bruh
send this to your brother water memes
how could drops of water know themselves
to be in a river
well i don't think i want the vin book
god that quote
oh it's he didn't make the quote okay
just like vinbo
it's so good
believe in your dreams
i don't think you need to attribute that
to anybody
it's like pretty generic it's like hey
these are all things that he posted
himself
yeah they're from his facebook page oh
that's [ __ ]
sick yeah he his facebook page
he he ran himself and it called it vin
book
oh he was very active on it the facebook
yeah yes yes i thought he was like
hinting at an actual book coming out no
no he referred to his page as vin book
and he would interact with his fans on
there all the time basically anybody
that submitted something he was just
very positive so he'd share all of it
wow i get really strong uh
jeremy reiner vibes redder yeah
for sure jeremy renner's kind of worse
though because he had like a behind the
paywall thing
yeah yeah render book was wow
he had the app right oh yeah
and he's like a multi-millionaire
hollywood star and he's charging his
fans for like
headshots [ __ ] weird
okay let's talk about rudy because like
i know you got i mean this isn't
politics but i have to say this is not
politics this is right straight up
dogery this is going down in history
rudy giuliani has been put in charge of
donald trump's legal battles in the
courts to try to overturn the election
i heard somebody from the new york times
describe
it as the republicans need um
lawrence of arabia and what they got is
curly mo
and and uh what's the name of the threes
curly mo and larry larry that's the joke
what's cause lawrence of arabia larry oh
that's not a joke lawrence arabia's a
great leader and kurt and then
three [ __ ] that's the connection
between the two that makes it
anyways it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter
larry is short for lawrence
larry yeah i don't think that was the
joke they're making
do you want to argue ethan you got to
move on it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter
well you know let's get to the bottom of
it ethan has this thing
i think it comes from his family yeah
someone will say something like a fact
like they know it for sure
and then everyone else is like you're
wrong and then they'll argue for hours
googling and like don't argue for hours
to figure out who is wrong
and who had it right i hope i'm the
least but like my brother and my dad
and like it's little things that don't
even matter no one cares
i did it to my mom recently but she said
something that was like so annoying she
said
what did you remember what she said uh
and i started arguing with her happens
weekly
no i don't know it doesn't god what did
she say though i wish i could give you
guys an example
what was it
anyway here's really giuliani so people
say apparently
hairdressers are saying it's not hair
dye
which makes sense to me because why
would
hair dye bleed i mean you wash it out
you don't eat it um
it could be what you said actually it
could be like a spray
that kind of adds color i think like
temporary
solutions it's super ghetto yeah that
means
like the morning of he put did some dark
spray to make
fill in his balding so here well
regardless of
here's what happened pennsylvania
michigan wisconsin
nevada and arizona so he's trying to
talk about how there's
an election fraud it was stolen i mean
really serious [ __ ] right and then
meanwhile
he's literally melting on camera 30
years ago
they had federal judges doing consent
decrees over elections
you missed it you missed george oh he
doesn't know it's there
he knows judges and federal authorities
monitoring the elections dude look at
you
i i can't say what's going to be done
about that oh he has drips on his
dome yes just got back from the jerk off
across from the four seasons
what's that what's that they said he
just got back from the jerk off booth
across from the four seasons total
landscape excellent
i i i know about it i i really can't
give you an opinion on that
uh i think obviously every election
official should learn something from
this
and be very very careful with the next
election i know this is a lot of
information
yeah why are you melting he's obviously
very serious individual
someone else i saw a tick tock where he
like blows his nose and then wipes it
all over
his face yeah it's the next link oh good
is that the one that
yeah that's that's actually the one
someone said oh that's the person oh
really i saw that
i saw that goodness this is how you win
cases in a courtroom
why isn't someone asking about it there
we go he just wiped it put in his mouth
don't go from bro
well if you thought that was gross i
mean he's literally
the most vile he is the most
vile uh and he's just such a fuck-up
this is the man who's in charge of the
most you know
he's sweating so much he's so wet
so it's just a shame that these people
are in a position of power because
they're actually funny like i just want
to
enjoy the humor i mean this guy couldn't
he couldn't [ __ ] care
i don't think this guy could win a court
case to save his life man
his hair guy is dripping down here 75.
why are you melting this is serious
stuff you know
this is just one week after he held a
press conference at
four seasons total landscaping i mean
the guy is straight out
just a few weeks after he got caught by
borat
that was all like this month dude he's
helping wearing like
pinocchio shoes just happened
this guy should be
that's what happens when he absolutely
yeah i mean every week with this guy is
something that i've never
ever seen before in my life here we go i
think this is the one i was describing
yo i can't believe this should check it
out
so let's ignore the fact how do i okay
here we go that nobody's wearing masks
because you know that's just imaginary
yo watch my bands over here
yo takes out the handkerchief
his nose takes it booger's side
in smears his hands all over it
in his mouth wipes it into his lips
all lovers in his eyes
so he's wiping snot all over his face
smearing his hands into it
looks like [ __ ] bro we're talking about
touch the podium yeah
he is so vile
and such a [ __ ] up i like that he then
like folds it nicely
kind of and puts it back like he thinks
he's very respectful
yeah right i mean this is donald trump's
personal attorney
why does he not have better
representation
like you know giuliani used to be a
respectable guy
he used to be the mayor of [ __ ] new
york city
life is strange man
yeah remember zorg zork from fifth
element
oh and here he quotes my cousin vinnie
which was you guys
like you were looking at this new york
times article
and i just thought it was so surreal the
title was like why is julie
rudy giuliani melting
[Music]
it's a serious article and they're
talking about how he's melting
yeah somebody's got to put this guy out
of his mid
somewhere you've got to let this guy
just
before you say that i actually have some
breaking news apparently
his son who was at that press conference
was just announced to have covered oh i
know i read that this morning i think
yeah well so so everyone is sick maybe
that's why it looks like
[ __ ] [ __ ] he doesn't look healthy so
not at all i don't know if it is a
symptom of like sweating [ __ ]
out of your pores about fever well i
don't know
the drip but his son apparently works
with
him and trump and all that so yeah i
mean there's a good chance he's he's
gonna
he's gonna get i mean i don't know how
he's not gonna get covered up there
doing what he's doing
far away probably the closest they got
is from
dude chris christie's fat ass was in a
was in a he
was in an er for like two weeks
they're friends with him and they still
don't care
like they're they're close confidant and
friend was in here
for two [ __ ] weeks and i saw that he
he said that he was really keeping it
safe for the longest time and then he
kind of
got loose and went to that one event and
then he got it
who chris christie yeah yeah i would be
scared to get if i was chris christie
that guy is not
that guy's foo that guy's foopish
maximus
here to the back of that room we could
do like a um
did you all watch my cousin vinnie do
you know the movie
it's one of my favorite war movies
because he comes from brooklyn
and when the the nice lady who said she
saw
and then he uh he says to her how many
fingers do i how many fingers do i got
up
and she says uh three
she was too far away to see it was only
two
these people were further away than my
cousin vinnie was from the witness
they couldn't see us okay we're gonna
quote moving
okay better better overturn the election
stop freak out
stop the vote keep the vote
[Laughter]
i mean look i try not to yeah this
stuff's really been bothering me yeah
i'm just getting nothing
eat out my ass treat all the girls like
trash
i just feel like everything it's a [ __ ]
there you go it's the [ __ ] that will
get you
it's just not normal you guys what
what's happening
it's just so far from normal it's not
normal
it's just not okay like it's just so
[ __ ]
odd it's not
normal guys
it's not normal for a president to tweet
out uh conspiracy stuff
q a i won the election twice
once in all caps once in it's all small
within eight hours of each other
it's not normal anyway let's get over
that
okay we wanted to watch this and get a
feeler
apparently this is uh
i don't know if this is a big deal or
what but
um damn dan wanted to watch this
it's the trailer for the new justice
league
made by zach schneider now zack
schneider
always makes movies that look good but
are always really bad
well well he made
300. he made 300 which everybody loves
and he made a watchman which i think
half of people loved
but he made a lot and that we just
watched no no not the
so anyway you guys to kind of tell me is
it just have a song this is it's not
worth getting claimed for this [ __ ]
here i'll just mute it
oh [ __ ] oh no it's not that it's a
hallelujah which i was like oh it's a
shrek song
what are we talking about the song that
is playing the whole time is just
hallelujah
hallelujah and i was like oh it's shrek
first yeah yeah yeah it's a shrek sounds
track song for some reason every shrek
soundtrack song is just a shrek song
forever
like smash mouth is shrek shrek mouth
somebody once swamped me an onion
in a motion
well anyway um
baby games uh he thinks it's gonna suck
oh yeah well i'm just baffled why it's
black and white
it's like a try hard yeah yeah that's a
good way yeah if you could hear the
music
here i'll play the music for a second
this isn't just another movie
it's is the movie actually black and
white no stop
it's just yeah i think it's going to
suck all these superheroes whenever they
get together
trailer alone tells me this is going to
suck i feel bad for ben affleck because
i really like
him like who's here as batman our best
friend well this isn't even like a new
movie this is and
that came out a couple years ago yeah
but this is like
people they're saying what are people
complaining about
oh internet cutting out is anybody
paying attention
everyone's saying f f huh
i mean what's happening are they just
saying f for the trailer
um no it does have an error they're
lagged for a second
i guess it live yeah i think we're back
back the internet might have just
dropped out for a moment yeah i think it
just went out for a second and
we're back anyway
so what this is not a new movie no this
is the one that came out a couple years
ago
wait what the why are we talking about
it now yeah what
well you don't know what the why am i
watching this it's been
released it's being re-released zack
snyder didn't
originally make this movie oh so what
does the schneider cut
okay so he was making this movie and
then he had a personal tragedy and
dropped out and joss whedon took
over and made the justice league movie
it came out it made a lot of money but
pretty much universally everybody i
never watched that yeah i skipped that
[ __ ]
yeah it's it's a bad movie 6.3
damn that's brutal and then for years
fans of zack snyder have petitioned
warner brothers to let him finish
his original version of the movie that's
what this is but they already filmed it
so what does that mean he's just gonna
make some cuts here and there yeah it's
like a special edition of the movie i
think they shot
some new things but not much it's mostly
just
and then they redid the cg and a bunch
of [ __ ] nice things but there's like a
massive amount of hype
building up to this and uh and i think
it's going to suck just as bad as the
first one
well how much how much can you polish a
turd right
right
we put some some uh shrek music over
that and you got yourself a uh
rodeo
shoenice is in the chat and he's typing
trump and he's typing ethan is a loser
oh he is awesome
[Laughter]
can we get him to call in i'm sorry i
put him in timeout at the same time
should we have him call in yeah tell him
not to kill me
dan's saying no i kind of want to check
him out real quick
let's just check in on him shoe message
zach if you want to call
in i may you know i'm not
i'm not guaranteeing a lot of air time i
just want to see how you are
i don't know if he is he in the discord
i mean he's messaging
and he's a member i think we banned him
from the district we banned him from
discord why
because he was he was harassing people i
think so
come on man get your [ __ ] together
you're wrong about that
i mean i didn't personally ban him but i
want to say something did somebody ban
shoe from discard
that happen at one point i didn't ban
him i think we may need like a separate
way to get the shoe line yeah we need
like a separate
people like skippy and q and stuff yeah
people we want yeah
we need a vip number yeah shoe can you
message um
zach please i want to talk to you guys
if you want just a heads up according to
one of his more recent videos he's
really
not happy with you guys again well when
is he ever happy with us
right yeah where is really should i open
it
yeah he's been drinking which i'm not
happy about but i'm not his mom i'm not
his [ __ ]
caretaker you know what can i do
you know but i do want to check in on
them
let's see i don't see i don't see
anything about me here
shoe nice 22. i think it got deleted
yeah that sounds like chill
okay this is because i don't wake my ass
bro
this is the best this is the best this
is confirmed real
this is not a joke this is 100 billion
percent real the pope
likes this image on instagram
this is confirmed this
is one billion percent real the pope
el he liked this [ __ ] post on
instagram
straight up nice straight the [ __ ] up
so there's been great stories like this
before like ted cruz like in
stepmom porn on twitter and stuff but
this is the pulp
amazing the pulp don't be friends with
the pope man you want to be
yeah he's got good taste zach you guys
have a lot to talk about
oh yeah me and the pope
uh who knew the pope is the ass man
clearly oh this is her
i guess it's kind of nice in a way is
just a guy
he's just a guy he likes acid like
everyone else you want to look at the
positive side
somehow hey if god didn't want him
liking that photo he wouldn't made that
girl's ass so fat
right
right
uh she made a comment about it she's
noticed the po i'm trying to find it
the explanation
oh she said my mom hates my aspects but
the pope
would be double tapping the holy ass man
she's so funny about it she said i found
her calling in life
oh i saw her just explaining the story i
don't know where it is but she was
saying like
she just noticed all of a sudden that
the pope liked their photo
and she went and clicked it and it was
the real pope yeah
and then she she put it out there
pope francis ass
that's from the chat frances yeah
so the vatican has launched an
investigation
into the origin of this like a
full-blown investigation
i love it hope liking suggests to photo
brazilian model
um they're gonna they're gonna put
someone
as a backup story and blame him yeah
they're gonna
they're gonna throw some intern under
the bus like ted cruz did but you know
it was ted cruz yeah
the question is let's go to pope francis
did pope francis like the ass
or was it a [ __ ] what
you know i wonder who runs the pope's
account if it's just some like uh
[ __ ] you know intern they found on
someone who forgot to switch accounts
yeah like it's just uh it's just some
normal dude
you know what i mean i mean it's equally
as embarrassing like it doesn't matter
yeah
i think i can roll the pope out at first
i was like god i hope it was actually
the pope
but he definitely has nothing to do with
this account
you know it's just weird photos of him
being like
this
i am the pope you come you come onto my
insta
you come onto my instagram account and
you like big brazilian ass
[Laughter]
when did i deserve this disrespect but
you know even the people who manage his
account are probably really
i'm assuming it's not just like a young
intern
is it dude whoever did that has got to
be scared
because the vatican don't [ __ ] around
when they find you
yeah they'll make sure you go to hell
they'd be like yo god this thing
is this guy she has been blessed like
literally blessed
yeah wonderful i wonder if she probably
got so many followers
dude getting a pope like yeah getting
the pope to like your ass photo on
instagram is like
like play that church music you know
like gregarian chance could you have
anything like that zach
yeah let me pull it up pull that up i
mean we say papa bless but when popeye
blesses you
this is it when you lex your ass
angel gets its wings a new girl got her
fat
ass wings a new influencer a
uh when the pope likes a fat ass the
fart fetish just smells of fat nice fart
from a big fat ass
where's that gregarion chat zach it
seems to be
uh read out in my database
great do we have her account
i think let me get a picture of her ass
can we go through her account
you got it right here
[Music]
this is what the pope does when he jerks
off when he comes
oh he probably has a live
music someone is yeah he's got a whole
choir in the pope's chambers or maybe
there's a wall so they don't have to see
the action taking place
[Laughter]
[Music]
she's a lot now i don't know if she was
big before she's 2.5 million
we got to do a stained glass window of
her in the [ __ ]
in the vatican because this is the
blessed ass
there's no ass like this in the world
[Laughter]
can we actually get a stained glass
window we gotta i want to do this
this is the blessed ass i think we need
to give reverence to this
momentous occasion
[Music]
all things are possible with god you
know they say that the pope's actions
are ordained by god that everything he
does is ordained by god that means that
god
[ __ ] wants to hit that ass that's
right
what are we going to do he did it
through the hand of the pope
exactly the pope was like jesus god is
leading my hand
oh lord double tap that ass
by the blood of the lamb by the poop of
the ass
if they're not going to honor her she's
going to have it on the set or something
yeah
yeah yeah can i get a copy of that
but you'll get to you'll get to see it
when you come to work yeah you mean you
get the photo
the photo's there man anytime you want
it anybody on the audience if you've got
if you've got a
you've got a stained glass guy send them
our way we'll find one
maybe look into that your research all
right
is the [ __ ] now anyway
and now the vatican's going they're
trying to
approach the church or the instagram
vatican wants instagram to explain why
the pope's account like the photo of the
brazilian motto
what like okay dude chances are
the dude was logged into the pope liked
it it's not instagram's fault
again it's like oh what happened to god
god's plan for everything god
obviously wanted you to like the [ __ ]
like there's no accident you've got
dealing god god is infallible all of a
sudden with covid and with
joe biden winning and with liking this
brazilian model's aspect
all of a sudden god doesn't know what
he's doing anymore
instagram made an error no god [ __ ]
made this happen bro
their whole their whole the whole con it
doesn't it's not consistent you know
what i mean
everything is happening as it is so
where's the acceptance
there's no acceptance
i feel like i'm making a lot of sense um
you are
you're really making a lot of sense i
hear you a lot i i agree with you right
like where's the consistency
just [ __ ] own the ass shot i'm gonna
eat your sandwich we're deep in this
show now
i mean he's a human being i mean humans
gonna do it
that one fell on the floor oh there's no
you think the pope
uh is a virgin no way man
he's theoretically he is
i ain't probably [ __ ] people are
asking why you're not talking about
trisha do you want to oh
yeah i mean we'll talk about it on
monday yeah he's just gonna say with
different enemies
makes more this isn't a world of [ __ ]
she's part what the
[ __ ] drama she's like drama getting
ground zero
[Laughter]
yeah i mean we'll talk about eating
fatty i don't want to talk about it a
lot
fatty well you're fat
thanks i'm just trying i'm hungry i've
been going for a while
you're a fat fat fatty it's just one
bite of bread
i don't see what's the big deal i really
need rude
um go pee pee you have a
probably a bunch of donations we can
read off real quick oh amy
yep okay we have
we have dodo's bizarre adventure for
five dollars i bought an ethan ass
kindle
can't wait to destroy my respiratory
system and make covey jealous
you're doing good work out there keegan
for ten dollars says hey i want to thank
you guys for supporting mental health i
was just diagnosed with bipolar disorder
and i'm now seeking treatment thank you
all thanks to you
all that's a tough one with treatment
treatment's really good i'm glad you're
getting help for that we have someone
who goes by merchant for a hundred
dollars so i just wanted to show some
support
stay golden age three podcasts
thank you thank you please send love
um ray uh brady said everyone wants to
mention ila's hair but let's appreciate
ethan's
luscious flowing hair okay thank you for
coming back
thank you for acknowledging me you know
i'm ready for a haircut again
yeah it's it's like this is is the most
surprising part because they
all warned that that was going to take
forever but yeah i was expecting it to
take a long time and you know i shaved
them again like a week or two later
right for another look and i don't want
to say i've got freakish
my my toenails grow freakishly long too
i feel like
so i'm a freak should be something
[Music]
i love your hair you always look like a
goddess and your hair is bomb ethan
you're also
good and look like a a goddess
i look like a goddess i'm really happy
that i'm finally trying stuff with my
hair
you've never dyed your hair before right
no
it's fine
play the gregarian champ
god thank you can i get a pope like
can the pope like you listen of the lamb
by the blood of the lamb god
by the blood of the lamb
i love that gregarion chance eh victory
victory victory victory victory victory
why do all these people love trump by
the way he's like the most unpious
person in the world
like joe biden is actually a good
christian dude like he goes to services
every weekend he's like actually a
religious
uh like pious person
[Music]
but trump is like literally not he's
like so unpious he's so doesn't
okay whatever let's talk about uh small
pp energy this is
this is a good one that's better so
there was a lot of
people very upset about the fact that
harry styles wore
a dress on vogue yeah it was like a huge
[ __ ] issue on twitter
with all the you know the usual suspects
like ben shapiro go
mashi and candace owen tell us about
what bishop pereira thinks about fashion
the guy well here let me let me show you
so this was the photo shoot harry styles
with the war dress and a vogue photo
shoot he's been doing it for a minute
it's kind of cool
it's been yeah he's been doing some like
gender it's not even gender bending
really it's just
more like just playing around with
fashion right yeah
also it's high fashion he's working with
like
the creative director of gucci and yeah
it's this is not for ben shapiro
that's well said for sure well they go
they they say
word let me show you so anyway this is
the photo shoot
yeah these are good looks i mean this
isn't really feminine at all it's pretty
badass
this giant the giant shane yeah
the [ __ ] that giant chain is pretty next
level
i mean so that's it he's actually really
working this stuff like he's still
i don't know i mean it looks cool on him
this look i'm not saying i don't know
but yeah but like this look i mean just
on a personal level just
as a fashion uh fashionista that's funny
me commenting
but you know you look but like but um
but i like these looks a lot i like this
look a lot but anyway i appreciate
it so
these are trend setters sure
so anyway this whole photo shoot set off
a
a uh avalanche of
conservative outrage starting with
candace owen she says
there is no society that can survive
without strong men
the east knows this and the west the
steady feminization of our men at the
same time that marxism is being taught
toward children
is not a coincidence it is an outright
attack bring back
manly men she's living in like the game
of thrones life
so the east and the west
over here let me just continue so ben
shapiro picks this up who's obviously
known for being the most
masculine man at 5'4
you know high-pitched voice
there's there's been extra large and
extra hard
ben shapiro short he said in his bio he
says he's like uh
5 10 or something but he's clearly like
5'4
not that i'm making fun of his i didn't
care about his height
but i'm just saying like for a guy to
talk about today can we get like
can you look at this though
oh it's a photoshop damn they got me
good
he's not the id he's not the idea of
masculinity i mean to
a guy anyway he says this is perfectly
in response to candace owen
this is perfectly obvious anyone who
pretends that this is not a referendum
on masculinity for men
to don fluffy dresses is treating you
like a fallen idiot a referendum
one photo shoot is the whole
establishment
saying that men need to [ __ ] put on
skirts i mean what the [ __ ] are you
talking about
masculinity and femininity exists
outward indicators of masculine and
feminine exist in nearly every human
culture boys are thought to be more
masculine in virtually every human
culture
because the role of men is not always
the same as the role of women
the left knows this of course the point
of styles doing this photo shoot is to
feminize masculinity
otherwise why would it be headline
worthy for styles to don a dress
the left knows this
they openly see that gender is both
important and socially constructed
which is why they tell you that a man
can be a woman eg despite no biological
i mean the guy is so
so here's my take on this
oh he made a whole video about this
jesus man [ __ ] milk it
and not only word is female genitalia to
the whole dress
conversation outward indicators of
masculinity and femininity exist in
nearly every human culture
right we train little boys to be
masculine and we train little girls to
be more feminine
read out of them the toxicity of
masculinity or the toxicity of
femininity we try to use civilization to
civilize children but boys are boys and
girls are girls right and these are
important
god what a way to kill the vibe this guy
yeah that guy ruins every part listen to
him talk about anything
it's art you dum-dum let me caress about
what you think
go wear your bland t-shirt and go on
with your life no one cares
i'll just keep showing the um the
reactions before i give you my take
he said there's so much joy to be had in
playing with clothes oh
yeah i've never thought too much about
what it means it just becomes this
extended part of creating something
that's a very [ __ ] fair statement you
know what i mean like
he's just having fun with clothing yeah
this person says
is this somebody she says what is wrong
with you people
absolutely insane and demonic
what's more insane a dude having fun
with clothes are you caring that much
about it
pretty sure you're saying it's demonic
it's kind of like
mental it's a bit over the top in it
when children draw their sticks like
figures in school
they put the dress on a female who do
who do the
put the dress on now and who represents
who's female and male
imagine the confusion that one's nobody
but i just
i saw that comment it really cracked me
up god he's not even the first guy to
put on a [ __ ] dress like why is
everyone losing their [ __ ] over this
this is
you know pop stars gender bending
has been a thing for a long time i mean
even though it's back to david bowie
it's kind of been a thing this year it's
not like he's
that groundbreaking with this um post
malone's been wearing like
dresses and skirts lately it's it's just
fun
who cares about i don't know why he's
getting the ire of the conservative but
here's my take
candace owen says there's no society
that can survive without strong men
this is an attack bring back manly men
okay first of all you can be whatever
the [ __ ] kind of man you want
this doesn't this is nothing to do with
his masculinity he still looks very
masculine to me
and the fact that like there's no such
thing as manly man i mean look at the
people who are the most popular
in pop culture right now you have people
like joe rogan who are so [ __ ] alpha
male that his
balls probably drag on the [ __ ] floor
when he walks i mean the dude literally
injects testosterone into his neck every
morning
like there's no lack of manly men
there's a whole diversity of man you
could be able to [ __ ] you want
you know i don't know why everyone has
to conform
to your idea of masculinity you dumb
[ __ ]
weirdo what does even marxism mean you
freak [ __ ] you
that's i'm caught up on the east knows
this
i've got to assume she means china
that's because that's usually when the
conservatives are upset they're
referring to china
the east knows this right but i think
well what they mean is the general like
uh
china japan southeast asia kind of thing
yeah but then she goes
what do they know what do they know that
we don't know right and
but and then she goes on to say that
it's not a coincidence that this is
being taught to us at the same time as
marxism
china is a communist country yeah what
do they yeah
get your messaging straight by the way
have you seen japan high-fat the
japanese are like the most stylish [ __ ]
ever look how they dress
you know what i mean like the the
japanese people their idea of like
um gender anything
gender norms like they are way in the
future candace owen does not know what
the [ __ ] she's talking about
like sorry you're just you're so
ignorant
um japanese fashion there i saw a
blogger
i can't wait to someday go to japan such
[ __ ] drive it's just such
nonsense they're just they're so stupid
so they don't know what the [ __ ] they're
talking about it sounds so
angry like they're so angry and just
like they don't this is just a fun
little thing like what do you guys care
about it so much
i think it's cool i think it's very rock
and roll it is i mean yeah
i think putting on a skirt is rock and
roll it really is
i mean all the way back to [ __ ] elton
john
david bowie you know the pesh mode i
mean
in the 80s like so stupid every hair
metal band
yeah i mean they wore makeup i mean they
were actual makeup
you know what it is the statement is
like i'm so comfortable in my
masculinity
i'm so confident that i that this
doesn't make me feel insecure
so confident in my own skin that i can
explore
anything it's just like it's really
inspiring if
anything that it's like
you there's no manly men
what's next we're gonna talk about
feminine women
yeah they do i mean yeah they love
talking about that okay they want
conformity they want conformity
and they want everyone to think and feel
and act the same way
which is funny because they there's no
consistent messaging it's all just anger
and fear where's the love and it's
grifting too frankly they're all
grifters because
they all survive they all make a living
from peddling this [ __ ] fear so they
all over
reacting to every [ __ ] thing we try
to get clicks
such grifters
i just find it odd that now is the time
that they
that they went after harry styles you
know
anyway yeah very odd
and of course
ben shapiro is such an obnoxious [ __ ]
god
just so obnoxious
it's just it's not a referendum on
masculinity
is it challenging the idea of
masculinity i mean what's wrong with
that
if if joe rogan put on a dress would you
be happy
if you wanted to i don't give a [ __ ] joe
roca puts on a dress
i'm just saying that the notion that
masculinity is under attack
is blatant [ __ ] when joe wrote when
joe rogan's the most popular
like you know alpha male
kind of [ __ ] is like super popular right
now this whole like alpha male thing
i mean joe rogan lives on elk meat do
you understand
like he's over that kind of matthew
lenny to me is kind of cringy it's like
so over or
over that to me wreaks insecurity
to me but everybody could be whatever
kind of
masculine man they want whatever
masculine means to you
i think it's quite masculine the way
that he's able to wear a dress and be
confident
you know and trust me there are plenty
of women who would uh
reach under that dress this guy says one
thing that annoys me is that girls can
wear
boys clothes but boys can't wear girls
clothes even just the color pink i get
cold gay
right and you know that is so stupid
yeah i agree
whenever i show my mom like our teddy
fresh designs
you know it's really colorful for guys
and she's always like can guys really
wear that
and i'm like yes mom yes
yeah and so it's just a color i agree
yeah that's a really good point
you know women can wear jeans and
t-shirts and
that's just another one of the kind of
double standards like i don't see
candace owen and ben shapiro making all
these high
er but yeah you're right you should be
able to wear what the [ __ ] you want dude
anyone want to disagree anyone want to
call and debate me on this
any manly men in the alpha males who
think this is a referendum on
masculinity
is there anybody in the audience who
injects testosterone into their
child they would like to call in
this person is saying i think shaming
man for
wearing feminine clothing is an attack
on masculinity
good point that's a great point
let's get some calls going zach i want
to get some people comment on this
that's a really good point
you know it's like men have enough
pressure to conform
conformity is usually almost always
trying to wonder is conformity almost
always bad i don't know but i don't know
what that means
but conformity is like the antithesis of
american id
uh individualism
back in the day women couldn't wear
trousers that's right
let me see if he was wearing trousers
right now what the [ __ ]
i don't feel comfortable in dresses at
all it's like i hate
dresses hate it it's a nightmare for me
jack we have people calling in uh no one
wants to call in
nobody wants to call him what the [ __ ]
kind of show we doing here
you don't have to disagree i guess
nobody not not one soul
okay ain't do you disagree the ian isn't
here
yeah what about regularity
yeah do you think international men's
day
kind of upset him and he because he's
not a real human you know
oh the men's day got to him huh yeah
he's sold he's disappeared i don't know
where he went it was a little bit
triggering
yeah is that a uh is that a hammock for
your cat that i see in the background
yeah he's supposed to though oh can we
see it
he loves it how does it work
you suction cup it to the window and
then
he loves that he gets his little view
out there you don't open the window do
you
no no yeah not this one and i don't have
cats i don't know
talk about the baby out the window the
baby with the bath water
the other one does sometimes if i open
him too much he puts his whole body
weight against the screen and i panic
yeah that's scary
well speaking of international men's day
[Music]
i'm waiting for a call but you know the
quartering we did a whole thing on the
quartering
he he in our content court declared
international men's day dumb then all of
a sudden
when international men's day came around
he got really defensive
he said pride pride month is dumb black
history month is dumb international
women's day is not international
wednesday's time and we made fun of them
because him like i don't know how you're
lumping him men's day with pride in
black history month like
right okay but okay whatever so then he
says it's all dumb
but all of a sudden men's day comes
around and he's getting pretty defensive
about his day
samantha bee just said you know another
reason to stay indoors
obviously just a little tongue-in-cheek
he says you're a [ __ ]
like bro you have [ __ ] you have a
problem doc
what kind of person is spending their
time tweeting stuff like that you're a
[ __ ] like that's not even funny that's
just like an attack yeah
like i think you're a douche bro you're
like not funny
or interesting you just go you should
just go be in your basement
i just beat in my basement
i just peed in my basement
my wife i pee in my basement that was
belle yeah
that's awesome i just been in my
basement um
my wife just went out for pizza without
me
my wife went out for pizza without me
by the way he made these like super like
uh frantic videos about how
he made it sound like the whole video
was just about his wife
this is so sick yeah it's like some
trumpism deflection where it's like
that's not even what it was about it's
not even close to what it was about
he says you're a [ __ ] and then he quote
tweets it and just says [ __ ]
oh my god in case somebody
missed his uh slam dunk tweet
dude i i think i have a feeling i know
what the quartering feels about
hairstyles wearing a dress
dude you're such a this guy she just
god these these people man
[ __ ] what can you say about a guy like
that
so is there really nobody that wants to
call in i don't know i do want to call
him somebody
uh somebody gave a hundred dollar
donation said i drive three hours a week
for work and podcast makes the drive so
much easier
thank you guys love to hear it
thank you so much you know i'm seeing
lots of members come in i don't know
what's going on but i thank you for that
all you guys it's really nice
see um well i'm at the end of the line
here so i was hoping to get a call to
extend this episode a little bit but
we're going for uh two hours
13 minutes okay
well we'll be back next week we've got
frenemies
which is going to be a wild ride there's
a lot of drama
that trish is involved in it's gonna be
a lot to talk about
trisha has been going after charlie
dimiglio
who's 16 years old number one creator on
tick tock
um what the [ __ ] i was i saw the whole
thing blowing up on twitter
i was just checking it out really quick
and i just didn't get it
it's still spiraling i mean it's still
happening but i don't get what it all
even started over it
seems so blown up well okay so
i don't i don't know if i want to get
into it now because we're gonna have to
cover it all but
someone mentioned logan defending her
yeah i saw logan you know
the set this clip's actually pretty good
maybe we should watch this
so logan was defending
harry and i have to say that bring
back um what's his name of his co-host
mike oh mike mike is such a dude the
more i see mike the more i
dislike him i have to say and i
apologize but i have to say logan
logan really uh stood his ground here
and
i respect his position obviously i agree
with that
but these guys really represent um
really represent what's out there like
they get so they actually get upset and
they go
uh it's not masculine bro
it's like okay dude i don't know what's
masculinity to you but to me
he still looks masculine actually in
those clothing so it's
that just goes to show you like anyways
it's all different in
our heads let's just hear let's watch
manly men
because harry styles wearing a dress in
a field
so my question is that ain't manly bro
[ __ ] that ain't you gotta you gotta
sound like that
that ain't manly bro there was some
other guy that wasn't
yeah yeah no no well that guy's on i
know something mike but that's the other
guy on the show
mike gets what does it mean
is manly like being comfortable in your
own skin and being wearing a baseball
hat backwards
bro what people think about what you're
wearing i get that and i understand it's
okay
and try new things and do things and i
and i think it's great for people not to
judge
other people but yeah man just like you
are now okay
he can also have his opinion why are you
getting um combative the
the the you guys are making this
something you're you're the
you're the type of people that look at
it like oh man gotta be men and they
can't wear dresses
none of us suck a dick by the way i i i
that hit the fact that he said suck a
dick
i didn't see anybody pointing that out
and i thought it was so funny yeah
that he's going on this thing about how
manly man and all this and
be free to be who you are then he used
to suck a dick as a derogatory
i i don't know why no one pointed that
out i was desperate to see
because it kind of undermines his
argument it's funny i know i think
they just think about it yeah it's just
a figure of speech you know
we've all been saying suck a dick for so
long i mean sucking
dick is one of the greatest things a
person can do for another person
i get one of the nicest things i just
get like getting so immediately heated
up you just want to say
something yeah yeah i i i'm not sick
calling him a homophobe or anything like
i'm just saying it's fun it's just funny
yeah but yeah i mean you know i think we
all agree that dick suckers are some of
the finest people
uh among us
yeah these are these are the people we
should be building statues
front lines ground zero
we love our dick suckers yes we do we do
this in a heartbeat no one's no one
knows that i wouldn't do it
no one said he didn't no one said that
what it
the notion of it the idea of it the idea
of him donning a
a magazine dress in a dress
elicits a conversation and it's a
conversation the problem is people are
too quick to get angry like you you get
angry at our opinion and i think
and i think that's not fair what am i
angry about you got really quick to get
mad at me and mike
immediately there's no conversation you
just got mad immediately
yeah because it's like you know your
position is just
sucks your position just kind of like
represents hate
yeah if you don't get that then i'm
sorry but yeah
i also get hit it up immediately when i
hear stuff like that yeah it's such
[ __ ] it's like
it's like some opinion because the next
thing is to call in oh it looks good
yeah and then right it's just it's a
position of hate
if you don't know what it represents
your position is aggressive
it's not masculine you know
it's like so yeah it's cool that logan
had a good take
although i have to say this this clip
went viral and it's like
you know it's like
logan paul just has to [ __ ] have a
decent thought and then everybody's sick
in his praises you know what i mean
yeah well he [ __ ] up so many times
that
he's the suicide forest guy he's playing
on easy mode now though it's a little
ridiculous the bar got lower
at least he's doing it though he's
saying the right things yes true
by the way his friend has a jesus fish
on his arm which means he's like uh
i think that's like a devout christian
thing so it explains once again
that candace owen by the way is such a
hateful [ __ ] toxic person
to even agree with her on anything
should really give you pause in life
i mean truly and utterly she really is
i'm listening to you
telling me you don't want to judge
people and then watching you judge
people so yeah i'm listening and
no one's judging you i'm not getting
angry but nobody's calling you out for
your flaws you are
you're just you don't know what you're
saying so now i have a flaw from my
opinion
your lack of so it's a logic but saying
i just
your opinions aren't just opinions
sometimes like people i get i run into
this all the time people go yeah jews
are greedy
jews just i just don't like jews it's
like okay well
you will [ __ ] like i get mad and they go
it's just an opinion
i'm entitled to have an opinion it's
like well some opinions really
you know yeah are is is it
you know it's it says a lot more than
just
somehow we can just we can dismiss
anything as just an opinion because of
this
uh what do they say on the right the
democratization of ideas or whatever
or the the what is it they say like dave
rubin says you're talking about the
marketplace yeah the marketplace of
ideas
look i just think you should be
exterminated what's to the market place
of ideas bro you could disagree with it
why are you getting mad it's just my
opinion that all jews should be
exterminated
that's a fair point i'd be like that's a
fair opinion but
i disagree with it um but you're
entitled to your opinion
[ __ ] so my my point of view is a flaw
you're
not reading that yes it is yes point of
view is a flaw see what i'm saying about
you being
angry you just assaulted me do i look
angry with you and
do you know what assault means i'm
telling you that your lack of logic
will lose you the argument when you say
yeah like people shouldn't judge people
but like
this is he's not a man because he's
wearing a dress
never once said i said he's not a man
for wearing a dress you said it's not
manly right
in the same vein it's not man i did not
grow up where i walked around watching
men wear dresses
now that is upbringing and my
surroundings it wasn't my choice and it
wasn't the way i wrote it
but you can't get mad at me if me and
mike are like you know we don't see it
yes you can he's so stupid listen i just
think that you should be exterminated
off the
place of the planet you can't get mad at
me this is my opinion obviously it's an
extreme version
of but that that's just get tired of
people saying hey he's just an opinion
and get
mad at opinions right i mean
yeah i don't understand that that's
definitely the nazi
people think that jews should die it's
their opinion i don't know i don't get
that argument
lead to action well whatever it's
obvious it's self-apparent
does anyone want to call in so in the
chat people are saying there's
a lot of people but then zack and a.b
are saying they have no one what's that
i don't know what's happening
yeah is anyone not messaging you guys
not working
clearly you're not getting any messages
i know i literally
i just i i just got one right now this
is my first one
i'm let me know i mean about having that
let's go everyone just wants to talk
about poop
yeah yeah guys we're gonna talk about
hopefully we can't do that anymore
so no more poop balls i'm putting i'm
putting the kai watch on it
anything else i'm literally asking if
anyone has an opinion on this
conversation i don't want your poop
story right now you guys
this is not about poop
all right
dead air so next week we have frenemies
which is going to be crazy and wild and
then we have um
we're going to try the clip show which
we don't have a title for yet but we'll
call it something like
fat fat juice should be exterminated uh
react
just an opinion
oh i like ethan i like ethan reacts
bad lame really lame okay all right
let's keep thinking
and then we've got um after dark
do we only have three episodes next week
yeah i guess so
it's also thanksgiving next thanksgiving
that's true
not that i'll be doing anything yeah it
doesn't really mean anything
thanksgiving for whatever that's worth
um
people in the chat are saying there's a
lot of people in that want to call so i
don't know what to tell you
these guys i have there's nobody there
i have one right now uh
cat boy i'm a transgender guy and i love
to discuss gender and gender norms with
ethan and ela
are you looking for someone to be more
uh
opposing opinion yeah
probably
thank you for trying catboy but
all right i'm getting out of here i'm
getting out of here
stop well it's friday so thanks
everybody for tuning in it was another
great show
and um next week's a new week next
thanksgiving so
you know happy thanksgiving we can't
control what everyone does but you can
control what you do just keep yourself
safe because you don't want this [ __ ]
it's not worth it
and the whole damn crew it's not a
regular flue
happy thanksgiving to everybody uh to
all the crew
the cast a b ian dan zach we love you we
appreciate you happy thanksgiving to you
stay safe you guys all are you guys
doing thanksgiving
i'm not going anywhere no no dan no no
no maybe now
we're going to see each other before
thanksgiving right yeah i mean
are we recording a couple episodes are
you doing anything for thanksgiving you
answer the question
no keeping it keeping it mellow what is
keeping a melamine are you seeing
someone outside your house
i have sam in my house that's smelly
right that is mellow yes
zach you live in your household it's
pretty mellow
might do something with a friend not too
sure okay like
being home hmm we've got a yellow
warning on zach
oh that's what theaters yeah all right
guys
we'll see you next week all right take
care
yeah i don't know you're listening to
the hp podcast
what we got on the scene could it be
papa's united bill delfin
talking front wiper back wife what you
gonna do with me then you know
and the whole damn crew goose and gaps
with all the guests you'll see
the best podcast in the world take it
from me jc